[Music]
alright hey gonna be here in LA a lot of
pretty girls here I find it hard to
approach women at a bar I feel like
women should hit on men more hit on us
ladies you can say whatever you want to
a guy I had no lady approached me once
she goes ooh I'm gonna kidnap you I was
like wow I could never say that to a
woman I said that to a lady she calls
the police I would be curious to know
what a woman can say that would offend
me like all right I'm gonna take you
home drugged you take advantage of you
and film it I'd be like all right well
least let me pay for the uber I'm just
jealous you gals you have options you
have the freedom to say no well a girl
goes on a date with a guy and this guy
takes out his Nazi memorabilia she's
like I get the hell out of here if I go
on a date with a girl she takes out her
Nazi memorabilia I'm like I gotta bang
her and get the hell out of here it's
just tough to date now you know we have
no patience anymore we want everything
immediately now we wanna think quick we
want Oberer tinder Netflix every so
quick now the only thing we don't want
quick is sex when's that gonna catch up
yeah I was with a girl the other night I
finished kind of early she's like hey
what's going on here I was like wow
these are the times we're living in come
on I don't the patients your vagina to
be buffering let's go cows are so sexy
you drive me crazy this is how sexy
girls are I was out to dinner wants his
girl leans over during the meal and goes
hey I'm not wearing the underwear oh my
god that's hot then I realized why is
that sexy
has underwear every day huge obstacle
for a guy has any guy ever taking the
girls jeans off seen panties been like
oh it's gonna be a long night put a pot
of coffee on I can't crack that code
that's how hot you are girls you can
tell my article of clothing you're not
wearing I can't even see it missing I'm
already turned on doesn't work for me as
a guy I can't pull that off I lean over
during dinner hey I'm not wearing
underwear she's gonna go uh-oh what
happened yeah I learned the hard way you
can't say sex on a date girls hate that
it's like saying bomb at the airport the
whole thing shuts down yeah
it's weird we all like sex it feels good
but you can't bring it up the only way
to get the thing you want to pretend
like you don't want it
that's weird behavior what if job
interviews were like that so mark why do
you want to work here who says I want to
work here I don't know maybe it's me
maybe I'm screwed up sexually now I cut
my parents having sex when I was 8 21
and today the idea of your parents
having sex is so horrifying isn't it
that's why I'm surprised parents will
use that as a threat wouldn't it be so
effective like hey Timmy better clean
that room mean your mom are gonna go at
it I don't let Matt test Billy I got a D
I'll show you some D I don't know the
gays have it figured out yeah I love a
good gay my roommate is gay I like
having a gay roommate he's gay I'm broke
I feel like poor people and gay people a
lot in common you know
all right we're both born that way yeah
yeah women just want to be our friends
and when you finally tell your parents
they're like yeah we know I went to the
gay pride parade a couple months ago
still sore had a good time yeah yeah the
homophobic guys out there with the big
signs you know how much have to hate a
group to make a sign I'm never gonna
sign my whole life these people more
prejudiced I am productive yeah the
markers the poster board I don't get it
your tactic for fighting gays as arts
and crafts might want to rethink that
one ironically the group you hate the
most really pizzazz up that poster
I have the worst gaydar in the world - I
can't tell who's gay I don't know my
roommate was gay till we had sex the
Bible hates the gays - boy the Bible is
a real buzzkill huh don't like anything
fun the Bible hates gays they hate trans
that's gonna be great we're doing stuff
so sexually advanced not even in the
Bible no like I love having sex with my
robot the guy's like all right you're
good anybody and now I'm trying to be
more PC I'm not good with the PC you
know I find it very phony now you know
pcs phony because you've never used it
an emergency
there's too many syllables the words
would take too long you know people are
hurt you gotta help them you don't time
be progressive you gotta be quick like
if you saw a Chinese guy get into a car
accident run over a black guy you can't
be like oh my god officer come quick but
a terrible tragedy an Asian American man
got into a car accident not cuz they're
bad drivers he ran over an
african-american gentleman who's cross
the street slowly not because they do
that and you gotta come quick the guy's
really hurt he's drowning in a pool of
his own blood not cuz they can't swim
[Music]
thanks a lot I'm mark
[Applause]
you